[Music]
[Music]
so
good morning everyone the
9010th meeting of the security council
is called to order
okay
i'll give the floor to the russian
federation
president
before you dub the agenda
to convene a security council
in connection with the
terrific provocation of the creation
of forces
from the beginning
the first meeting which we requested on
the third sunday third of april for
monday at 3 p.m and then an emergency
meeting which we requested
at 12 o'clock on the 4th of april
after you refused our first request
second time
uh issuing a decision that wasn't
coordinated with anyone that it would be
better to discuss this topic today this
is
an outrageous situation
set out in my
letter to you yesterday as an official
document of the council i would like to
ask you on what basis
do you
feel that you can act in such an
outrageous way uh
all existing norms and rules don't you
know that that in case you don't agree
with our proposal you should have
convened these meetings
forward
the issue of the advisability of holding
a meeting or vote
especially since you should have uh had
before you the example of our presidency
where we didn't refuse a single time
any of the six meetings in ukraine
we demand an explanation
from you and we hope that in the future
you will not challenge the right of
members of the security council to
request the uh meeting
enshrined in two meetings of the
security council at the request of any
member of the security council
there he was thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation
is there anyone else who wants to
comment on this i will
explain
the presidency's position in just a
moment
okay
if i could
respond to your points
from the ruston federation we did uh not
reject your request for a meeting we
received your letter uh on
sunday and it is the responsibility with
the obligation of the presidency to
schedule a meeting
you particularly requested a meeting for
a time on monday uh our proposal as
presidency was to schedule the meeting
either alongside the meeting today so
well within the 48 hour limit which is
the convention of the security council
or to hold the meetings sequentially one
after the other and i understand that
the russian federation turned down both
proposals but i wish to be clear that we
did not reject the request for a meeting
the deferral proposed was
less than 24 hours
and
to be clear
we share the view that this is an urgent
situation uh and we have as i say
offered the russian federation either a
separate meeting today or to combine it
with this one and so as far as the
presidency is concerned uh we did
everything in line with the provisional
rules of procedure
and with precedent we have received no
other complaints from council members on
the subject
i give the floor to the russian
federation
but i want to express that
thank you
thank the representative of the russian
federation uh the presidency will not
refuse to host meetings uh in the future
uh and i hope that that now closes that
point and we can proceed with the
adoption of the agenda
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
letter dated the 28th of february 2014
from the permanent representative of
ukraine to the united nations address to
the president of the security council
s slash 2014-136
the agenda is adopted
i should like to start by taking the
opportunity to pay tribute on behalf of
this council uh to her excellency lana
nasa the permanent representative of the
united arab emirates
for your service as the president of the
council for the month of march
i'm sure i speak for all of us
in expressing our deep appreciation to
ambassador saber and her team
for the skillful
conduct of the council's business last
month thank you very much indeed to your
team
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representative of ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
on behalf of the council i welcome the
participation of his excellency mr
vladimir zillienski the president of
ukraine
and just add that as usual precedent the
permanent representative of ukraine will
also join the meeting in case of any
technical issues
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
miss rosemary de carlo under secretary
general for political and peace building
affairs
and mr martin griffiths under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs
emergency relief coordinator
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i also invite his excellency mr olof
skoog head of delegation of the european
union to the united nations to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
i wish to warmly welcome his excellency
the secretary general his excellency mr
antonio gutierrez and i give him the
floor
madam president
excellencies
the war in ukraine
is one of the greatest challenges ever
to the international order and the
global peace architecture founded on the
united nations charter
because of its nature
intensity and consequences
we are dealing with the full-fledged
invasion on several fronts one member
state of the united nations ukraine
by another the russian federation a
permanent member of security council
in violation of the united nations
charter
and with several aims including
redrawing the international recognized
borders between the two countries
the war has led to senseless loss of
life massive devastation in urban
centers
and the destruction of civilian
infrastructure
i will never forget the horrifying
images of civilians killed in butcher
and i immediately called for an
independent investigation to guarantee
effective accountability
and i'm also deeply shocked by the
personal testimony of rapes and sexual
violence that now are emerging
the high commissioner for human rights
has spoken of possible war crimes grave
breaches of international unitarian law
and serious violations of international
human rights law
and the russian offensive has also led
to the displacement of more than 10
million people in just one month
the fastest forced population movement
since the second world war
far beyond ukraine's borders the war has
led to massive increases in its pride in
prices of food
energy and fertilizers because russia
and ukraine are linchpins of these
markets
it has disrupted supply chains and
increased the cost of transportation
putting even more pressure on the
developing world
many developing countries are already on
the verge of debt collapse due to the
impact of the kov 19 pandemic
and the lack of adequate liquidity and
debt relief
stemming ultimately from the unfair
nature of our global economic and
financial system
for all these reasons it is more urgent
by the day to silence the guns
that is why ask the emergency leave
coordinator martin griffiths to travel
to russia and ukraine to press for an
urgent humanitarian ceasefire
and the secretary general griffiths will
update you on the humanitarian situation
and the results of his contact so far
and the secretary general dicarlo will
also brief you on the political and
human rights
but secretary general united nations it
is my duty to call the attention of the
council
to the serious damage being done to the
global economy and particularly to
vulnerable people and developing
countries
madam president
our analysis indicates that 74
developing countries with a total
population of 1.2 billion people
are particularly vulnerable to spiking
food energy and fertilizer costs
debt obligations take up some 16 percent
of developing countries export earnings
and in small island developing states
the figure is 34 percent and rising
because of increased interest rates and
the need to pay for expensive imports
in the past months alone which prices
have increased by 22
miles by 21
and barley by 31 percent
brent oil prices on the 1st of april
were more than 60 percent higher than at
the same time last year
a series of events have led to that not
only the present situation
natural gas and fertilizer prices more
than double over the same period
we are already seeing some countries
move from vulnerability into crisis and
signs of serious social unrest
the flames of conflict are fooled by
inequality deprivation and underfunding
with all the warning sign signals
flashing red we have a duty to act
madam president the global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance that i set up last month
has formulated some initial
recommendations for the consideration of
member states international financial
institutions and others
on food
we are urging all countries to keep
markets open resist unjustified and
unnecessary export restrictions and make
reserves available to countries at risk
of hunger and famine
this is not the time for protectionism
humanitarian appeals must be fully
funded
people crop up in crisis around the
world cannot pay the price for this war
our on energy the use of strategic
stockpiles and additional reserves could
help ease this energy crisis in the
short term
but the only medium and long-term
solution
is to accelerate the deployment of
renewable energy which is not impacted
by market fluctuations
these will allow the progressive phase
out of coal and other fossil fuels
and renewables are already cheaper in
most of the cases
and on finance international financial
institutions must go into emergency mode
we need urgent action by the g20 and
international financial institutions to
increase liquidity and fiscal space
so that governments can provide safety
nets for the poorest and most vulnerable
the reform i've been calling for the
global financial system is long overdue
all these actions are closely linked
with the prevention agenda and with
building and sustaining peace
madam president the war in ukraine must
stop now we need serious negotiations
for peace based on the principles of the
united nations charter
this council is charged with maintaining
peace and doing so in solidarity
i deeply regret the divisions that have
prevented security council from acting
not only on ukraine but on other threats
to peace and security around the world
i urge the council to do everything in
its power to end the war and to mitigate
its impact both on the suffering people
of ukraine and on vulnerable people and
developing countries around the world
and i thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
remarks
i now give the floor to ms rosamuticalo
thank you madam president since i last
briefed this council on 17 march the
security situation in ukraine has
seriously deteriorated
the number of ukrainian civilians killed
has more than doubled
ukrainian cities continued to be
mercilessly pounded often
indiscriminately by heavy artillery and
aerial bombardments
and hundreds of thousands of people
including children the elderly and the
disabled remain trapped in encircled
areas under nightmarish conditions
the devastation wrought on mariupol and
other ukrainian cities citiz cities
is one of the shameful hallmarks of this
senseless war
the horror deepened this past weekend as
shocking images emerged of dead
civilians some with hands bound lying in
the streets of bucha the town near kiev
formally held by russian forces
many bodies were also found in a mass
grave in the same locality
reports by non-governmental
organizations in media also allege
summary execution of civilians rape and
looting insur nahith harkeef and kiev
regions
madam president away from the fighting
diplomatic efforts to end this war
including direct talks between ukrainian
and russian representatives have
continued
we commend the government of turkey for
hosting these discussions as well as the
efforts of many others engaging with
russia and ukraine to help bring about
peace
we welcome the willingness of the sides
to continue engaging to reach a mutual
understanding
this requires good faith and earnest
efforts
and progress in the negotiations should
be translated quickly into action on the
ground
while there has been a reported
reduction of russian troops in attacks
around kiev and chernihief
such moves should not be merely tactical
repositioning forces for renewed attacks
on ukrainian cities and towns elsewhere
the general assembly has twice called
for russian forces to withdraw entirely
from ukrainian territory and cease all
military operations
we also take note of the reported
withdrawal of russian forces from around
the chernobyl nuclear site
the international atomic energy agency
reports
that this development will hopefully
allow it to conduct an assistance and
support mission to provide technical
advice and to deliver equipment where
necessary as soon as possible
all nuclear sites in ukraine must be
fully protected and secured
military operations in around these
locations must be avoided
madam president
the numbers tell a tragic if yet
incomplete story
according to the office of the high
commissioner for human rights
at least 1
480 civilians have been killed and at
least 2195
injured between 24 february and 4 april
2022
ohchr believes that the actual figures
are considerably higher
we are gravely concerned by the
persistent use of explosive weapons with
the wide impact area in or near
populated areas
such weapons are causing most civilian
casualties as well as massive
destruction of civilian infrastructure
including residential buildings
hospitals schools water stations and
electricity systems
ohchr has received credible allegations
that russian forces have used cluster
munitions in populated areas at least 24
times
allegations that ukrainian forces have
used such weapons are also being
investigated
as noted by the high commissioner
indiscriminate attacks are prohibited
under international humanitarian law and
may amount to war crimes
the massive destruction of civilian
objects and the high number of civilian
casualties strongly indicate that the
fundamental principles of distinction
proportionality and precaution have not
been sufficiently adhered to
in besieged cities a significant
increase in mortality rates among
civilians can also be attributed to the
disruption of medical care and basic
services
people with disabilities and the elderly
are particularly vulnerable
as of 4 april 2022 the world health
organization has reported a total of 85
attacks on health care facilities
resulting in at least 72 fatalities
and 43 injuries
madam president we are seriously
concerned about reports of cases of
arbitrary arrests and enforced
disappearances of persons who have been
vocal against the russian invasion
as of 30 march ohchr has documented the
arbitrary detention and possible
enforced disappearance of 22 journalists
and civil society members in kiev
hairsun luhansk and zapporigia regions
24 local officials have also been
detained in regions under russian
control
13 of whom have been subsequently
released
we call for the immediate release of all
individuals who have been arbitrarily
detained including journalists local
officials civil society activists and
others
also as of 30 march ohchr has recorded
seven journalists and media workers
killed since hostilities began
another 15 have come and come under
armed attack nine of whom were injured
allegations of conflict
related sexual violence perpetrated by
russian forces have also emerged these
include gang rape and rapes in front of
children
there are also claims of sexual violence
by ukrainian forces and civil defense
militias
the u.n human rights monitoring mission
in ukraine continues to seek to verify
all these allegations
we're also concerned about disturbing
videos depicting abuse of prisoners of
war on both sides
all prisoners of war must be treated
with dignity and full respect for their
rights in accordance with international
humanitarian law
madam president the many credible
allegations of serious violations of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law from
areas recently retaken from russian
forces must not go unanswered
we support efforts to examine these
allegations and to gather evidence
ensuring accountability and justice for
acts committed during the war will not
be easy but it is essential
madam president we are heartened by the
generosity of neighboring countries who
accepted millions of refugees and the
solidarity of the ukrainian people who
are hosting their displaced compatriots
with more than 10 million people
displaced either within ukraine or
abroad as refugees
roughly one quarter of the population
the united nations is gravely concerned
about the heightened risk of human
trafficking
indeed
suspected and verified cases of human
trafficking are surfacing and the
surrounding countries according to the
international organization for migration
madam president this war is devastating
ukraine now
but it also threatens its future
early assessment projections by undp
suggest that if the war continues
through 2022
ukraine faces the prospect of seeing 18
years of socioeconomic progress lost
this would set the country and the
region
back decades and leave deep long-term
social and economic fissures
un agencies including undp are working
to help preserve ukraine's hard-worn
development aims gains
this involves supporting the government
to sustain
essential government structures and
basic services including emergency
measures to sustain livelihoods such as
cash-based assistance
madam president the war in ukraine has
damaged europe's security architecture
its economic repercussions are already
evident far from the battlefield
the longer the war continues the greater
the risk that it will further weaken the
global institutions and mechanisms
dedicated to preserve peace and security
the war was started by choice
there is no inevitability to it or to
the suffering it is causing the united
nations is ready to do everything in its
means to help bring an end
to it thank you madam president
i thank mr carlo for her briefing
and i now give the floor to mr martin
griffiths
thank you madam president um as you've
just heard from
the secretary general and under
secretary general dicarlo
ukrainian civilians are paying
far too higher price for this war
i want to speak briefly about
humanitarian needs and what we're doing
to meet them before i then
refer to my recent travels
in the last six weeks as we have heard
at least 1 430 people have been killed
among them
over 121 children and we know this is
very likely a serious underestimate
homes and civilian infrastructure
bridges hospitals
schools
have been damaged and destroyed
and in fact the current figures on
displacement
tell us that more than
11.3 million people have now
been forced to flee their homes and of
that 4.2 million in our refugees
in those generous neighboring countries
that rosemary has just been referring to
so in total more than a quarter of the
population of ukraine has fled in this
extraordinary
a short time
unfortunately we can imagine that these
figures will continue to rise until we
can find
a pause
and some peace madam president the
ground and air offensives and
counter-offenses
are making life nearly impossible for
many civilians in ukraine families the
elderly women and children have been
trapped by fighting already for too long
for more than five weeks
the people of mariopol have been caught
up in the fighting
and it is well documented that really
maripole is a center of hell
other cities like chernohev sumi and
kharkiv remain cut off from essential
goods and services
and perilous conditions are hampering
our efforts to access civilians or for
them to access us
and we restate here that civilians must
be allowed to move
to safer areas without the fear of
attacks
and at their own choice and at their own
selection
it's vital that all parties
uh to the conflict respect their
obligations under international
humanitarian law to protect civilians
and to allow impartial humanitarian
organizations safe
rapid unimpeded access to all civilians
in need wherever they are
in ukraine
madam president as the world watches
humanitarian needs saw in ukraine
the united nations
and our partner organizations are making
every effort to dramatically increase
our support to affected civilians the
work of the 6 000 volunteers
from the ukraine red cross as we have
noted before in this chamber together
with local ngos in eastern ukraine
these people these organizations
continue to work tirelessly tirelessly
at the front line of assistance to
communities
the world food program has reached more
than 1.3 million people with cash and
food assistance and plans to push that
number up to two and a half million
people in this month
health partners report
that more than 180 tons of medical
supplies were delivered in ukraine
with another 470 tons
on the way
this will address the health needs of
about 6 million people in the months
ahead
and i'm pleased to say that seems an odd
word to say in the context
of ukraine that after much effort in the
past day another convoy
went from our humanitarian hub in
dinipro
to the far east
today food winter clothing non-food
items medicine hygiene kits were
offloaded to the ukraine red cross
and will reach the hands of those most
in need
indeed following notification
to both parties a formal process that we
and also the international red cross are
engaged in
four convoys in total from the un
have provided critical support to people
in some of the cities encircled by war
where on with and affected by ongoing
fighting several more are planned
so these are initial steps
but it gives us a basis to now expand
and taking our efforts up to scale and
expanding much more than one convoy a
day
as the secretary general and the under
secretary general's already said
i want to also join them
in expressing my concern over the
growing number of reports we receive of
human trafficking
sexual violence exploitation and abuse
in ukraine and in the region
and as there are such horrific incidents
as we are seeing
there overwhelmingly impact displaced
women and children
more than others
we are bolstering protection and
gender-based violence services
through agencies to provide specialized
care for survivors
and through the the
the wealth of civil society
organizations in ukraine
these services are designed carried out
directly in collaboration with and
through ukrainian civil society
including
very particularly women-led
organizations
madam president today i'm addressing you
from geneva
having just returned from moscow
overnight
as you know the secretary-general as he
said
charged me to bring both sides together
on humanitarian grounds to explore both
specific
and sustained ways to reduce
humanitarian suffering including in
particular
into aliyah but in particular the
pursuit of a humanitarian ceasefire
yesterday in moscow
i had long and frank exchanges with the
minister of foreign affairs sergey
lavrov
and his deputy sergey prashinin
and then separately
with alexander fuhrman the deputy
minister of defense
in my meetings
with these senior officials
i discussed also in addition
to these
possibilities of humanitarian ceasefires
i discussed the issue of humanitarian
convoys of safe passage
including the four which we've i've
already referred to
i outlined possibilities for building
further on that cooperation
sharing specific
suggestions for mutually agreed upon
military freezes
to allow for evacuation of civilians and
for the safe passage of life-saving aid
in effect for humanitarian pauses in
different parts of ukraine to save lives
and bring back a modicum
of
safety for those living in those places
my counterparts in moscow received these
suggestions assured me of their intent
to carefully study those ideas which i
left with them
and we agreed to remain in close contact
and i came away from these meetings
believing that we have a very long road
a long road ahead of us
but it must be traveled
and madam president we will travel it
tomorrow i hope to travel i plan to
travel to ukraine
to have discussions with senior
authorities
from the ukrainian government
in kiev on thursday on these same issues
and others that they will no doubt
present to me and also to see firsthand
with our crisis coordinator amin
the humanitarian response
madam president
thanks to generous
donor contributions
many from governments in this chamber
the humanitarian response since february
has indeed been scaled up allowing us to
meet the needs of one and a half million
people
we will need sustained financial support
for needs in ukraine
and like the secretary-general i want to
stress
as he has done consistently that funding
must not be diverted from other crises
and madam president
for afghanistan and that is one example
as you heard from david beasley last
week
conflict climate shocks covered
compounded by the soaring food and fuel
costs
indicated by the secretary general
could push another 47 million people
globally into severe food in security
and so the total number of people around
the world who will not know where their
next meal comes from could be driven
to the astonishing figure
of
325 million people around the world
that is by a long distance the highest
in our recent history and well over
double
what was what it was three years ago so
madam president i close of course
like others by reminding the council of
what the council already knows well
the world cannot afford this war
and neither can the people of ukraine
and like others i call on all council
members and member states with influence
to support all efforts from whatever
part they come from in the pursuit of
peace
and the alleviation of humanitarian
suffering for the sake of the people of
ukraine
for the sake of those around the world
who cannot afford to bear the additional
burden
this war imposes on them
and all of us we must as the secretary
general said
silence the guns thank you madam
president
i thank mr griffiths for his briefing
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr vladimir zelensky the president of
ukraine
you have the floor sir
thank you very much
members of the security council and
other members of this meeting thank you
very much for this opportunity i'm sure
that all the representatives of the
united nations member states will hear
me today yesterday i returned from our
city of butcher recently liberated from
truth
for and purposefully killed
they killed entire families adults and
children
and they tried to
every single day in the memory of the
civilians who died
they were killed in their apartments
houses
the civilians were crushed by tanks
while sitting in their cars in the
middle of the road
just for their pleasure
they cut off
limbs cut their throats their throats
[Music]
terrorists
through their system of propaganda and
political
corruption promote a global food crisis
that could lead to famine in africa
asia
and other countries and will
surely end in large political chaos in
many countries
is but the world
has yet to see what they have done in
other occupied cities and regions of our
country
geography
might be different of various but
cruelty is the same crimes are the same
and accountability must be inevitable
ladies and gentlemen i would like to
remind you of article one
chapter one of the uh
[Music]
[Music]
as a result of russia's actions in our
country
in ukraine the most terrible crimes of
all time
we
in the temporary occupied territories so
that as many civilians as possible are
killed there
the massacre in our city of butcher is
only one unfortunately only one of many
examples of what the occupiers have been
doing on our land for the past
and there are many more cities similar
places
the world
ukrainian communities
each of
them is similar to buddhism i know and
you know perfectly well what the
representatives of russia will say
in response to the accusations of these
crimes they have said that many
the malaysian times
over donbass by russian forces with
russian weapons or during the war in
syria
they will blame everyone
just to justify their own actions
that is what we are interested in
maximum access for journalists maximum
cooperation with international
institutions involvement of the
international criminal court complete
truth and full accountability
i'm sure
those who consider themselves privileged
russia's leadership feels like
colonizers absolutely in ancient
times our wealth our people russia has
already deported hundreds of thousands
of our citizens to their country they
abducted more than 2 000 children
those children and continue to do so
russia wants to turn ukraine into
silence
the russian military are looting openly
the cities and villages
this is wide scale
looting they are stealing everything
into the right to die
this undermines the
architecture of global security allows
them to go unpunished so they are
destroying everything that they can
destroy
is
immediately
received
and then perhaps that would not be war
in my country naturally against our
against ukrainian people again
but the world watched and did not
which should be similar
uh
it's time to transform
in order to determine how we are going
from the world
borders and integrity of states and
countries
and it is impossible
with the ability to respond preventively
to security
ukraine is ready to provide a platform
for one of the main offices
similar to the geneva office that deals
with human rights nairobi office that
deals with environmental protection
uh
uh
would come
in dark times too and now we need
decisions from the security council for
peace in ukraine
if you do not know how to
make this decision you can do two things
either remove russia as an aggressor
and a source of war
cannot block decisions about its own
aggression its own war
do everything that we can
um
if there is
watch this short video
please give us one more minute
your time
one
because it is impossible to get everyone
to come to our country and see it with
your own eyes therefore i would ask you
to watch this video thank you very much
so
[Applause]
they have the video
i'm not sure the
video is that just coming
uh uploaded to the technicians of the
security council so they have it in
their position
i we
will sort that one out uh technically we
don't have the video
so i propose that while we sort that out
i thank his excellency mr zeliensky for
his compelling and powerful remarks
we will come back to the video when
we've sorted out the technical
the technical issues around it
and may i say speaking in my national
capacity may i express appreciation to
the president uh for his leadership in
wartime and for the extraordinary
fortitude and bravery of the ukrainian
people under this unprovoked and illegal
invasion
i resume my function as the president of
the security council and while we sort
out the
technical video i propose to give the
floor to those council members who wish
to make statements
and i now give the floor to the
representative of the united states
thank you madam president
let me also start by thanking uae and
ambassador nisabe for her successful
presidency
during the month of march
madam president
as you begin
your security council presidency i want
to thank the united kingdom for your
leadership and for organizing this vital
discussion on ukraine today
i also want to thank the secretary
general for his remarks and the other
briefers
and i'd like to extend a warm welcome to
president zielinski
i was so moved by the address he made
recently to our congress
and we're truly honored by his presence
here under the circumstances that he and
ukraine face today
madam president last night i returned
from a trip to moldova and romania
i saw with my own eyes the refugee
crisis caused by russia's unconscionable
war
i spoke to refugees who indicated to me
their desires to return
to their home
and we've all seen the images on tv of
the bummed out buildings
but what we have not seen
is that behind those destroyed buildings
are destroyed lives
and destroyed families
i met with women and children who had
fled ukraine who stuffed their lives
into backpacks and left the only home
they had ever known
and these were sobering conversations
one young woman i spoke to came with her
six-year-old brother
who had autism and is struggling with
cancer
their single mother helped them escape
to save their lives
but russia's war has interrupted the
care her brother desperately needs
another woman i spoke to fled with her
eight-year-old from odessa
the father
who they'd left behind
told them they were shelling right next
to their apartment that very night
and they very well could have died had
they not
left
a third woman i met
told me that she used to love to travel
but never expected her next trip would
be to flee her life
flee for her life
when i asked her where she was from
she started to say and then she stopped
with tears in her eyes and said i'm
sorry
i don't know how to say it whether i
live in kiev
or whether i used to live in kiev
she was realizing in the moment
just how dramatically her life had
changed because of this senseless war
these are three stories of more than 10
million
people
six million internally displaced four
million who have left ukraine all
together
4 million people who have relied on the
big-heartedness of countries like
moldova romania poland slovakia hungary
and others across the region in the
world to welcome and support all those
leaving ukraine in search of safety
ukraine's neighbors are bearing the
brunt of europe's most significant
refugee crisis since world war ii
and i want these countries to know that
they have a committed partner in the
united states
and that is why the united states
announced recently that we are prepared
to provide more than 1 billion u.s
dollars
in new funding toward humanitarian
assistance for those affected by
russia's war in ukraine and its severe
impact around the world
and it is why we are welcoming
up to a hundred thousand ukrainians and
others fleeing russia's aggression to
the united states
we will continue to assist humanitarian
efforts to help the people of ukraine
and all those fleeing putin's violence
but as heart-wrenching as the stories
are that i heard in moldova and romania
there are some stories
we will never get to hear
those of the people we saw in the images
out of bucha
we've all seen the gruesome photos
lifeless bodies lying in the streets
apparently summarily executed their
hands tied behind their backs
as we work to independently confirm the
events depicted in these images i would
remind this council
that based on the currently available
information the united states has
assessed that members of russia's forces
have committed war crimes in ukraine
and even before seeing the images from
bucha
president zielinski along with others in
the region were reporting that children
were being abducted and we heard him say
that today
also abducted are mayors and doctors
religious leaders journalists and all
who dare defy russia's aggression
some of them according to credible
reports including by the maryland city
council have been taken to so-called
filtration camps
where russian forces are
reportedly making tens of thousands of
ukrainian citizens relocate
to russia
reports indicate that russian
federal security agents are confiscating
passports and ids taking away cell
phones and separating families from one
another
i do not need to spell out what these
so-called filtration camps are
reminiscent of
it's chilling
and we cannot look away
every day we see more and more how
little russia respects human rights
and that is why i announced yesterday
that the united states in coordination
with ukraine and many other u.n member
states will seek russia's suspension
from the u.n human rights council
given the growing mountain of evidence
russia should not have a position of
authority in a body whose purpose
whose very purpose
is to promote
respect for human rights
only is this the height of hypocrisy it
is dangerous
russia is using its membership on the
human rights council as a platform for
propaganda to suggest russia has a
legitimate concern for human rights
in fact we will hear some of that
propaganda here today i know
and i will not dignify these lies with a
response
only to say that every lie we hear
from the russian representative is more
evidence that they do not belong on the
human rights council
140 u.n member states voted to condemn
russia over its unprovoked war and the
humanitarian crisis it has
unleashed
upon the people of ukraine
here's my message to all of you
now is the time to match those words
with action and show the world that we
can work responsibly
and i share president zielinski's view
that this moment requires responsible
world powers and global leaders to show
some backbone
and stand up to russia's dangerous and
unprovoked threat against ukraine and
the world
the secretary general said that
confronting this threat is the security
council's charge
it is
and it is also the responsibility of u.n
leaders and leaders around the world
every single member state with a voice
in the ga
no one
can be a shield for russia's aggression
suspending russia from the human rights
council is something we
collectively have the power to do in the
general assembly
our votes can make a real difference
russia's participation on the human
rights council
hurts the council's credibility
undermines the entire u n
and it is just plain wrong
let us come together to do what is right
and do right
by the ukrainian people
let us take this step
to help them to start to rebuild their
lives
and let us match the courage
of president zielinski who we are so
honored to have with us today
president zielinski
i want you to know that we stand with
the people of ukraine
as you face down this brutal attack on
your sovereignty on your democracy and
on your freedom
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement
and i give the floor to the
representative of
albania thank you madam president
let me thank ambassador lucie bear for
having steered our work during the month
of march and wish the uk a new madam
president
full success in our common work during
this month
albania welcomes president zelinski
presents to this meeting
his remarks are painful and his account
on what ukraine is experiencing under
russian occupation is revolting
we stand by you mr president by your
compatriots all ukrainians for their
heroic resistance for the resilience
that the entire world is admiring
you are not alone
you have the world on your side because
it's the raw is the side of the right
of the just and as we hope of victory
slav ukrainian
madam president let me thank sg
gutierrez for his again very clear and
powerful remarks
i also thank usg carlo and griffiths for
their updates
this is the 14th meeting of the security
council on ukraine since the 31st of
january while the war of aggression
has entered the second month
let's establish a few basic yet
meaningful facts
russia has stalled and its imperial
dreams are nowhere
taking ukraine finally proved impossible
kiev was too hard to swallow
russian army is in disarray but it has
not stopped shelling and bombardments
but all this is not new and all this is
not news the real news that has
horrified the world is what russia is
leaving behind
the unspeakable horrors those
soul-crushing images in areas from which
russia is withdrawing
images of civilian executed with a
bullet in the neck
sometimes with their hands tied behind
their backs or shot dead in their
bicycles
images of mass graves overflowing with
corpses
images of carnage and devastation
including looted homes rape and sexual
violence
acts usually attributed only to thugs
they spring from the same cruel impulses
as the bombardment of cities homes
hospitals schools and kindergartens by
the russian forces
butcher is an open-air graveyard
the notorious facelift of the russian
aggression
madam president we have heard time and
again
it is not russia
yes but no
it will be hard actually impossible to
convince anyone
that the destroyed tanks that clutter
the roads
the mines and booby traps left behind
amid the wreckage and the bodies of
civilians killed by arbitrary executions
and laying in the streets amidst debris
are staged scenes for propaganda
who would believe that russia aggressed
ukraine simply to protect civilians
while ukraine is busy staging horror
movies you may muzzle media back home
but you cannot fool satellite images you
cannot blind independent reporters and
human rights ngos on the ground
waiting for russia to accept and tell
the truth is waiting for god to arrive
and he never does
these are facts hard and sickening proof
of the atrocities committed the ugly
face of this madness
such crimes as documented by human
rights watch and verified by independent
and respected professional reporters
those who are banned for the russians
call for answers
call for thorough investigation for
effective accountability for justice
prime minister rama called these crimes
a terrible pain and a horrible shame
russia has an international obligation
to abide by international militant law
the laws of war including the geneva
conventions of 49 and its first
additional protocol
russia has an obligation to abide by the
order of icj to immediately hold this
military activity in ukraine
but unfortunately russia has made
another choice
not to respect any of it
and has cancelled itself from
international law
but the law will pursue it
russian army and its commanders cannot
escape accountability
the name of the butcher of maripol
a criminal that has reduced an entire
city to ashes
and has made its citizens go from three
meals a day to barely three meals a week
is engraved in the ruins of the city
this is why we will support the call to
suspend russia's participation in the
human rights council
the unga resolution that created the
council stipulates that and i quote
members of the council will respect the
highest standards in the promotion and
protection of human rights
as we see
russia's standards are nose eating and
its presence there is a first
a desecration of the place that is
called to be the sanctuary of rights
dear colleagues
russia has announced that it will now
shift its focus on eastern ukraine this
means that it will concentrate its
brutality there in what may end up
becoming a war of attrition
russia has blocked the renewal of the
osce international observer observer
mission in ukraine
this denies the international community
the independent eyes it needs there this
anticipates sadly more war
further atrocities other crimes even
more humanitarian disasters
this war continues to particularly
affect women and children millions have
been displaced many of them alone in
search of safety and security it is
heartbreaking to see mothers write names
and addresses in the back of their
children
so that they are recognized in case they
end up being orphans
we welcome the efforts of osha and its
partners to deliver assistance in
support of the people in ukraine and the
millions of refugees in neighboring
countries
madam president let me end with this
note
rarely has the outcome of a war been so
disastrously the up the complete
opposite of what it wanted to achieve
russia's army has been defeated by the
outgunned and outnumbered ukrainian
resistance
russia is isolated like never in its
history
it has become the world's most
sanctioned country in history
no country has ever seen itself
transform in a matter of only 10 days
from a global player into a financial
and international pariah
to the point that it is obliged to find
comfort in the support from north korea
and syria
dear colleagues
this aggression is and its startling
defeat have once and for all separated
the fates of ukrainians and russians
because the case of ukraine is also the
cause of democracy against tyranny and
kleptocracy
it is a fight between the will of the
people against the will against the
vicious will of one
whose reckless actions have challenged
everything we stand for and who is
directly responsible for the economic
disruption and food insecurity which is
affecting the entire world
he may choose to stop
withdraw troops and quit ukraine
or continue to descend in the very abyss
he has created and faced the
consequences
i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement
the images are harrowing
speaking in my national capacity
we are appalled
by what we have seen
and reiterate our solidarity with
ukraine
i resume my function as the council
president
and i now give the floor to the
representative of gabon
one day of war is one without a doubt
one day too many years and as the
conflict enters the sixth week the
number of displacements
is now surpassing the ten million mark
almost four million of which
as a result of the risks of food
insecurity
especially sexual violence
and humanitarian personnel
humanitarian workers working in theaters
of conflict should never be the target
they are not armed yes
yes they are very often the link between
veterans
and what remains of humanity when the
rug has been pulled
human humanitarian workers should be
able to file humanitarian assistance to
wherever it is
obstacles and in conditions of security
guaranteed by all
the exponential deterioration in living
conditions indeed survival conditions
very concerning
especially when civilian infrastructure
and the provision of essential
public services
we are concerned at the risks of
diseases
from water shortages
health risks ensuing from the lack of
access to primary or specialized health
care
women listen to children
should be able to be rescued in every
sense
that which binds us together as
humans it is precise
to reduce the effects of this break that
international humanitarian laws
give a free reign to the expression
is right in fact
it is to address through law a break in
the human country
all parties should abide
on persistence
them to ensure respect for their dignity
and we call for fears
and
thank you
i thank the representative of gabon for
her statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the russian
federation
delegation of the united arab emirates
for their presidency
we're also grateful to the secretary
general to rosemary de carlo and martin
griffith
for their briefings
we also listen to the president of
ukraine vladimir zelinski
we'd like to thank martin for his visit
to moscow
during which as far as we can
he had some useful meetings and
discussions
better than anyone else he should know
the efforts that russia is undertaking
every single day to organize
humanitarian corridors
however
the arrangements reached with the help
of uh international mediators
is consistently not being uh implemented
by the ukrainian side yeah
such communiques are published every
single day by our ministry of defense i
simply would like to say that just out
of my opinion
without any participation by the
ukrainian side we have managed to save
123 and a half thousand people
whoops should have slowing down overall
since the beginning of the special
military operation
over 600
000 people have been evacuated to russia
including over a hundred and nineteen
thousand children
we're not talking about any kind of
coercion or abduction
our western partners like
the voluntary decision by these people
is testified by many uh
videos that are accessible
in social medias
virtual presence here of the uh
president of ukraine and would like to
uh address
directions
now we place on your conscience
accusations against the russian military
which are not confirmed by any
uh any eyewitnesses and we spoke about
this in detail yesterday at our press
conference
uh including the russian-speaking
population which you pledged to protect
ukraine began to be transformed into a
hateful anti-russia and that seemed to
be on the verge of being turned off that
page of being
turned
no
those hopes uh failed to you know
who in fact threatened that uh the
residents of the donetsk and lugansk
will rot in their basements
calling on them to
return to leave to leave
in a country where russian is the native
language for a minimum 40 percent of the
past
because there was no
preparing already back in march to solve
the problem of the donbass by military
means in the course of our special
operations we have found many secret
orders testifying to this
we're told
that we can be no nazis
but unfortunately they are running the
shows
russians ukrainians and jews
nazi greetings and they're open about it
in the social medias
such as
the right sector and the other battalion
at the bill of alumni
heavy artillery next to residential
buildings and multiple rocket launchers
as well
today we've heard once again a huge
amount of lies about russian
uh soldiers and military we will not
hear you we have hundreds if
that russia was not letting people
through
taken
um
uh by soldiers with blue armbands those
are ukrainian insignias
uh
on the 25th of march
residential homes and in the courtyard
in the neighborhood around the drama
theater
a ukrainian
indiscriminately including targeting
the territory of the 16th 68th and the
fifth school
station i saw this with my own eyes
our building was badly
people's republic that helped evacuate
us
uh russians and ukrainians tortured
distributed
swastikas burned into their
chests
and
lay the foreign for their destination on
the russian military this is absolutely
unacceptable the fact that you even
consider that russia
is going to be capable of destroying you
now we're seeing
this
criminally staged
i understand that
ukrainian and western media
is
these are civilians
absurd information of the new york times
by delivering as much
but the most important thing
that nationalists are um
ukraine and would in time
because these are
people who are close to them
they couldn't care less about those
civilians they're ready to take to the
grave with them the entire population of
the ukraine as was clearly demonstrated
by them
it might be too late soon thank you very
much for your attention
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement and
i now give the floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i'd also like to thank the secretary
general and our other briefers this
morning
i want to express a very warm welcome to
president zielenski being with us this
morning president zielenski your courage
your leadership and the courage of the
ukrainian people
are an example to all of us
secretary general on the 24th of
february as russia launched a
large-scale invasion of its neighbor
ukraine you told the world that russia's
action was wrong
that it was against the charter that it
was unacceptable
we agreed with you however you also told
us
that this invasion was reversible
and called on president putin to end
this war to save innocent lives
we echoed those calls
sadly forty days later
our call has been left unanswered
instead
over the last forty days
we have witnessed unprecedented levels
of destruction
and human suffering
we are watching cities pounded by
russian artillery we are seeing millions
forced to flee their homes
seeking refuge from russian aggression
just minutes ago here in this chamber we
have seen the utterly shocking images
of civilians lying
dead in the streets of bucha and
elsewhere in ukraine some we know are
piled into improvised
mass graves
simply harrowing
so many innocent lives lost on our watch
as our pleas for peace go unheeded
the attempts here today
to deny russian culpability are frankly
appalling in their cynicism
and i see them as an insult to the
memory of those slaughtered civilians
madam president we roundly condemn the
atrocities reportedly committed by the
russian armed forces in a number of
occupied ukrainian towns
the images from bucha and other towns in
the kiev region liberated by ukrainian
forces
are horrifying
we here cannot suspend our humanity our
thoughts first and foremost must be with
the families of those killed
their pain at the loss of their loved
ones in such an unspeakable manner
is almost unimaginable
let's be clear
the russian authorities are responsible
for these atrocities committed while
they had effective control of the area
the russian authorities are subject to
the international law of occupation
there can never be impunity from such
crimes
never ever
not in bucha not another any other town
or village ever
for crimes have been committed they must
be fully investigated and evidence
preserved so that these crimes can be
prosecuted by domestic and international
courts including the international
criminal court
ireland will continue to support efforts
to ensure robust and independent
investigation of all violations of
international law
we must have accountability and justice
for the victims and for the survivors of
this war
we at this table share that
responsibility in face of such atrocity
we call on the russian federation to
abide by the order of the international
court of justice and to immediately
cease its military action and withdraw
from the entire territory of ukraine
madam president in the last 40 days we
have seen a horrific humanitarian
disaster
unfold in ukraine because of the russian
federation's unprovoked and
unjustifiable further invasion of that
country
a country where just weeks ago
citizens lived in relative peace and
prosperity and one which has been
transformed now into one where families
lack access to basic necessities
where basements have become bob shelters
where millions millions have become idps
and refugees
the use of explosive weapons in
populated areas has had a devastating
impact on civilians in the midst of
active hostilities
once again we call for the parties to
the conflict to comply with
international humanitarian law
including the obligation to direct
attacks only against military objectives
the prohibitions against indiscriminate
and disproportionate attacks and the
obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
we have heard increasing allegations of
sexual violence by russian soldiers
you referred to this this morning
secretary general
we must stress that conflict-related
sexual violence can constitute a war
crime
the perpetrators of such crimes must be
accountable
they must be held accountable they will
be held accountable
sexual violence is another abhorrent
crime of this war that cannot go
unanswered
we again reiterate the need for full
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
to those in need as called for today by
martin griffiths
secretary general we again echo your
call for russia to implement an
immediate humanitarian ceasefire
it is the very least the aggressor can
do it is way past time
as we know
the reverberations of this war
are reaching far beyond ukraine
it's unacceptable that russia's war of
choice against ukraine is also having
and will continue to have significant
spillover effects across the globe
deterioration of food security surging
energy prices
increasing poverty
the most vulnerable and impoverished in
developing countries will suffer the
most
we utterly reject that
madam president it is our collective
responsibility here at this table to
maintain international peace and
security
nothing less
this is why we call on the russian
federation to stop this war
to stop its unlawful attempts to
establish
occupying authorities to stop
destabilizing
the democratic foundations of the
ukrainian state
such steps are yet further reprehensible
violations of ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it gets harder each time to say this
but it is never too late to do the right
thing and to end this war now thank you
madam president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of brazil
thank you madam president
let me start by thanking ambassador
nusebe
along with her team at the uae mission
for compton competently navigating the
work of the security council in march
i welcome his excellency mr vladimir
zelinski president of ukraine
in the council today
i would like to thank the secretary
general antonio guterres
under secretary general for political
affairs rosemary dicardo and under
secretary general for humanitarian
affairs martin griffiths for their
updated presentations about the
situation in ukraine
madam president
as we enter into the sixth week of
hostilities in the ukrainian territory
we continue to witness appalling images
of human suffering
the recent reports of acts of violence
against civilians
in bucha erpin kharkiv donetsk and other
places affected by the conflict are
extremely worrying
according to the statement by the icrc
we call for a really independent and
thorough investigation
of all reported violations
with the full cooperation of both
parties to the conflict
without prejudging any conclusions
and underscore the need for perpetrators
to be held accountable
the international community is
witnessing for too long appalling scenes
of destruction of once peaceful cities
with shocking images from the conflict
and the desperation of thousands of
civilians trapped in the battlefield
with no food
no water and no electricity
once again
we renew our pleas for a broad effective
and immediate cessation of hostilities
in ukraine only after the silence of the
guns and the withdrawal of troops
are achieved will it be possible to halt
the immense costs of human suffering
this conflict has brought
madam president
the general assembly has recently
adopted a resolution
on the humanitarian situation in ukraine
as we said on that occasion
the general assembly could not become a
bystander of the shocking consequences
of the conflict
and
as we added last week in this chamber
neither
can the security council
as the main u.n organ with primary
responsibility
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
the security council has the mandate
and the responsibility
to address the situation in an effective
manner
and nevertheless
our assessment is that the security
council is failing in its role to help
in supporting efforts to foster a
constructive dialogue between the
parties
with the aim of brokering an effective
peer settlement
to this conflict
we deeply regret that the security
council has not been able to speak with
one voice throughout the crisis
promoting compliance with international
humanitarian law
protecting civilians calling for peace
these are objectives that should unite
rather than divide us
we should strive to create the
conditions for
on the one hand
invigorating the political negotiations
and on the other
reaching an understanding on practical
measures to minimize human suffering in
ukraine
civilians wishing to flee the
hostilities
must be able to do so in safety
and those who decide to stay
cannot become targets of attacks
in the same vein
parties must grant safe passage to
relief consignments to those in need
once again brazil reiterates the call
for all parties to fully respect
and ensure respect for international
humanitarian law
the causes of conflict whatever they are
do not undermine the obligations of all
parties
have to guarantee that civilians should
be protected
that the wounded receive medical care
that humanitarian assistance reach those
in need
and that detainees be treated humanely
in all circumstances
there must be no politicization of
humanitarian actions
nor selective application of
international humanitarian law
also
geopolitical objectives must not
supersede the endeavor for peace nor
prolong the human suffering
caused by war
madam president
this conflict
and its associated sanctions
apart from the enormous human suffering
and devastation
caused in ukraine
is having spillover effects in the
entire world
especially through increased prices of
oil gas grains and fertilizers among
others
food insecurity has become an even
greater threat to the world's poorest
people
above all in developing countries
the longer this conflict persists
the higher the risk of further
instability hunger and devastation in
ukraine
and around the world
it is high time to return to the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
for a peaceful settlement of the
conflict
we urgently need the cessation of
hostilities
de-escalation of tensions and
negotiations are the only way out of
this conflict
not only for the countries directly
involved but also for the entire world i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of brazil for
his remarks and i now give the floor to
the representative of kenya
i thank you madam president
i congratulate you on assuming the
presidency of the security council for
april and assure you of my delegation's
full support
i listened closely to the remarks by the
secretary general
and his under secretaries general
rosemary dicarlo and martin griffiths
hoping to hear that our fears that the
war in ukraine has entered a new
more dangerous phase were exaggerated
sadly they offered no such comfort
instead we are left with the words of
his excellency volodmir zelensky the
president of ukraine
who has described the horrifying
suffering of civilians in butcher and
other towns and neighborhoods in ukraine
his account of the atrocities
is in stark contrast to that of our
colleague in the security council the
representative of the russian federation
but the fact that the truth in butcher
is contested
is the surest sign that we stand on the
precipice of more widespread abuses of
human rights
in april 1994
even as genocide engulfed rwanda
there were members of the security
council contesting the horrifying truth
that a million people
were being murdered
we should stand warned that the
inability of the council
to establish the facts
and accordingly attribute responsibility
may enable the risk of escalation into
far worse crimes
beyond the city of butcher madam
president
we're extremely worried about the safety
of civilians who are trapped in other
besieged cities and villages
such as mario paul and kesson
our actions today should seek to prevent
what we have witnessed happen in butcher
take place
in mario paul and queson
while we debate who is responsible for
the horrors of butcher
it is incontestable that what started as
a special military operation
is now a war
and that what began with reassurances of
limited aims
not targeted at civilians has led to
thousands of dead civilians and millions
of refugees and internally displaced
no one can doubt that they are flagrant
violations of international law
international humanitarian law and the
u.n charter underway in ukraine
kenya condemns the abuses undertaken in
the past few weeks
and those in the eastern provinces of
the country during the years that the
conflict has reached
madam president
the war in ukraine is today's most
dangerous threat to the maintenance of
international peace and security
it is the latest assault
by the most powerful states against the
multilateral order
their continued abuse of the charter
created growing cracks over the years
in the global security order
now the bottom has fallen out ukraine
may now become a model for a new
generation of disastrous wars on
multiple continents
millions of refugees are being created
and there will be many more as the
economic effects of the war produce and
intensify conflicts elsewhere
accelerating food and energy prices are
plunging millions into worse forms of
poverty
the u.n as a forum for solutions to
humanity's most pressing problems
is losing prestige and its historical
standing
president zielenski has left us with
ideas for security council reform that
we need to consider seriously
things have fallen apart and the center
cannot hold under these assaults on our
united nations we must reform
there are no easy solutions
even a negotiation
that is not properly structured to
protect the people and sovereignty of
ukraine could be the prelude to a wider
war
for now we urge the following urgent
steps understanding their limits due to
the continued inability of the security
council to act decisively
we call for an impartial and prompt
united nations investigation into the
atrocities against the civilians in
butcher and other towns in ukraine
this calls for an immediate end of all
hostilities to guarantee unfettered
access by the investigating teams
we urge the conflicting parties to
immediately make clear to their military
personnel
that they will be held to account on the
basis of command or superior
responsibility if they violate the
international laws that regulate warfare
we commend ukraine's neighbors for
opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities from ukraine